We'll continue the discussion we left open last,
last time.
Remember,
we are all saying a few things about Ulysses.
Uh,
the overarching question of my remarks and your questions actually took my
remark in a,
in a,
in,
in a different and sometimes deeper,
uh,
direction than I had intended,
um,
is the whole issue of Ulysses.
But around Ulysses,
uh,
Dante's reading of,
what we call the Hellenic world,
uh,
and I'm Ulysses.
Ulysses is,
um,
appears in Canto 26,
uh,
with Diomede who is silent.
He races,
uh,
polio,
Tropic Intelligence of Classic Rock Antiquity,
the crafty,
um,
mind he's a,
he appears as a philosopher but also is a rhetorician.
And at the same,
and this is exactly the kind of complicity between the two modes that,
that,
uh,
Dante wants to explore.
Uh,
but let me continue with this overarching theme.
The overarching theme is the reading of a,
of the Greek,
the Greek world.
You remember that we saw a theocracy in Polynesia that clearly for Dante is a
knowledge which is filtered through,
uh,
a Greek Roman port stages who was born and lived in a Greek Roman city,
Naples.
Uh,
so he's,
he's discussing through a t is important is the whole story of feeds.
Uh,
the,
the two brothers who are enemies,
the enemies brothers.
And if for the tragic history,
the tragic not have a fever and a mythology that this Diomede who is,
uh,
who is silent and,
but above all,
the focus of the Canto falls on the,
the greatness of this hero Unisis who are repeat plays a pivotal role in Dante's
imagination is paradigm is a paradigmatic role.
Dante can quite get enough of him,
nor can he get over,
uh,
the,
the fantastic of Ulysses.
Ulysses literally appears in his dreams in Canton 19 of Purgatorio.
And then you list as will also appear when Dante is to measure the great
imaginative distance that he traveled,
that when he's at the border of the physical and the metaphysical worlds,
uh,
he looks back and he will see a Ulysses,
oh,
he remember.
He will see the place which has been the place of Ulysses transgression because
is apparently Julisa sin.
Use a sentence to have councils counseled his companions to go beyond the,
our boundaries of knowledge.
This is a,
so it's the effects of counseling.
Let me just say one thing that for Dante is no figure,
which is more interesting,
more important,
more full of for whom he has so many questions than the figure of the council.
The council was of course,
be of the Levenia.
How does he advice,
how does he take the pressure or he's the secretary,
the council,
how does he take the pressure of the court?
What does he council,
uh,
Frederick the great his emperor with?
And then we're going to see other councils we're going to find very soon,
later today,
uh,
province,
our port who literally advisors war between father and son.
He divides farther from Santa,
he breaches the unity of the body politic.
And then we'll come to that in,
in,
in fairness,
uh,
28.
So well you list,
this is the council who he gives the wrong counsel to his companions.
He makes rhetorical promises,
which he knows he cannot quite keep their grand questions.
But,
uh,
what questions does he,
does he pass on to this companions?
What he says is,
uh,
after the captivity,
after they're being in bondage to sin,
he wants to reform them.
The companions who was Yuna according to the story that Dante may have read in
medieval accounts with resist,
had been metamorphosed into hogs,
into pigs,
into a PQ regions,
had yielded to the pleasures of a sensual,
uh,
happiness,
essential understanding of happiness.
And he says,
you were not made.
This is where he,
the speech that he makes to his companions,
you are not made to live as beasts and allusion to Cersei,
to sources,
metamorphosis,
but to pursue,
to follow virtue and knowledge.
This is a grandiose,
uh,
advice that he gives.
And Randy also advice,
but,
uh,
which has one problem that Dante praises him.
And that's not necessarily the major problem.
He praises Ulysses and his companions as they are going to go beyond is they're
going beyond the pillars of Hercules.
It is as if Dante implies and seems to agree with,
if one were to read the trajectory of the divine comedy,
that there is no knowledge worthy of its name unless it is connected to some
degree of transgression that somehow transgression is part of knowing of an
original and new knowing your list.
This has to go beyond the limits of the known world in order to truly uncover,
discover something,
uh,
I new that nobody else knew that makes him as they used to say,
a renaissance figure.
Our let,
oh,
that's the way he's not.
And you know,
there's,
there's the famous joke of you listeners and then the graduate paper refers to
Ulysses as the great hero who is with a one foot firmly rooted in the Middle
Ages and the,
with the other one,
he salutes the rising sun of a,
the renaissance.
It's a little bit of a comical,
a account of Ulysses,
but it gives you a sense of how,
what the novelty that he,
he,
he represents.
So there is this,
this bit of a transgression that Dante doesn't seem to be a terribly bothered by
it since he himself and the different circumstances is engaged in exactly the
same kind of,
uh,
transgression of the perimeter.
The apparently the geographic that even the cosmic perimeter,
he goes beyond the son.
He's even,
he even goes farther then,
then Daedalus and certainly farther than Ecos.
This other mythical coordinates with them.
How does Dante find out,
uh,
how does he want us to full now that somehow the promises Ulysses makes to his
companions,
he wants to lead them to virtual knowledge may really be a faulty promise.
And this is the,
I think the substance of a cancel,
Dante,
we'll refer to it with a famous metaphor,
is a mad flight.
Remember,
Ulysses recounts how they made a,
made flowers flight out of the oars mixing metaphors.
It's done.
They had done before the,
the,
the maritime journey and the air journey.
This is the journey,
the flight of the mind,
the flight of the intellect,
as if were described by a Salem.
That Ulysses is a sailor.
What,
what,
how does Dante,
uh,
make us aware that this is indeed there's madness in what you listen is,
is trying to accomplish very simply,
he puts him within a peculiar,
distinct,
at the distinct political or rhetorical context so that you really have to
wonder can he's really delivered his promises and what of the political
consequences of the promises that he makes.
The whole,
the whole came to 26 is literally littered with fallen cities from this one.
It begins with Troy a with,
I'm sorry,
Florence.
Dante has this apostrophe against the city of Florence.
Uh,
the city of thieves.
That's what he calls it,
spreading its wings as if we're also as if cities were like heroes engaged in
great flights.
There's a clear desire on Dante's parts to have us connect to the story of
Ulysses,
uh,
self,
degradation.
Turpitude with a story of a,
of a,
of Ulysses Florence's,
uh,
turpitude and Julissa's own fall.
Then there is a reference to the city of Troy foreign city.
There is a reference Thebes with theft with through a key localism.
Polynese are there is also reference to Rome.
This hit the Kanto is full of references to cities from this point of view can
to 26 is a version,
a brief version of the epic because the impulse of the epic is always political
noise.
No epic that you can think of which doesn't think about is not trying to
represent the,
either the are falling cities and the edification of new cities or for that
matter,
uh,
some locating I say take,
it could be in a great ran metaphysical drama.
I could be in the heavenly Jerusalem or,
uh,
it's uh,
it's,
it's Rome,
it's car third.
It's Thebes falling cities and rising cities.
So,
uh,
this is what the,
the strategy of Dante Nantha strategists to show them how the grand
philosophical claims of Ulysses have effects that make it appear as empty
rhetoric.
He,
he down to praises Ulysses nowhere,
somewhere in the ocean without a particular place.
It goes from one city to another.
And at the same time,
because of this,
he can never quite,
doesn't seem to be able to deliver on what he has promised.
It's a reflection on one particular aspect of the tragic story of Ulysses.
It's the tragedy of language,
a language that contains with itself all the most incredible Mirages and yet
fall short of reality.
You list this is literally placed in,
uh,
in the,
in the empathy ocean,
uh,
away from all responsibilities and all locations.
And it is this gratuitousness of his quest that also counts for,
uh,
his being in a,
in,
in hell among the evil our counselors.
Um,
okay,
so this is what I was trying to tell you last time and I think that I have added
on today a few other details.
Uh,
but we can go back to that if,
uh,
if,
if there is to be a discussion and I hope there will be a little later.
Uh,
let me turn now to Canto 27,
which I really like to read in conjunction users should be read in conjunction
with Canto,
uh,
26,
because we,
here we have what I would call a counter myth two,
the story of Ulysses.
There is a contraction of focus.
Ah,
AH,
there's even a revision of the claims of epic grand jury that we have in Canto
26.
Dante meets and he's the one who become the interlocutor of Riedel.
The Montefeltro an extraordinary figure,
a political leader.
That's what he was,
who then experience the conversion.
He became a Franciscan friar.
And historically this is a historical figure.
Historically he's called in by the Pope Boniface,
the AA.
By now you know him.
He's not someone that Dante really holds in the highest esteem possible and he
bought one.
If it's the aid in an inversion of the relations between a priest and,
and uh,
um,
and cleric high priest and clinic asks Weeder da Montefeltro for some advice,
we are dealing again with evil counselors.
And the advice is the following.
You have to teach me you're a great man of arms.
You have to tell me what is,
what is,
what are the strategies I should pursue in order to conquer?
But it's three in a small town.
You may know there's a place where the origin of a great musician from there,
but a small town near row,
I want to conquer and destroy the city of Palestrina.
You tell me how I am to do this.
So we're really dealing with a machiavellian and machiavellian world of
counselors.
Uh,
uh,
for Machiavelli,
it's,
it's uh,
uh,
actually the language of Machiavelli.
Ivan Milat Makaveli users takes the language.
I think that that uh,
a widow will,
you were with DePaul it for himself at one point.
We dose as my works where those of a [inaudible] of a Fox and you remember these
are the two attributes or in the prince of Machiavelli that the man,
the,
the perfect prince or to have others to say,
uh,
the perfect princess,
the one who knows how to use strength,
how to use also slyness.
You have to know when you have to be crafty and foxy.
You have to know when to be,
to be violent and lie on like two images that clearly originate from Cicero.
They are not done for his own invention,
but,
and it's likely that Machiavelli got them from,
uh,
from,
from Cicero as well as from uh,
uh,
this,
this canto,
the connections between the two cancers are several.
And let me just go,
uh,
first of all,
it begins cantor 27.
This is the Sicilian bull.
Clearly a counter to the Trojan horse of the previous canter's Sicilian bull,
which bellowed for the first time it was just with a cry of him would shaped it
with his file used to Belo with the voice of the victim.
So that low it was the brassy had seen pierced with pain.
That's etc. Uh,
what is the story?
It's exactly the same version in a said,
demotic vulgar version or the grade situation of what has happened to Ulysses.
Ulysses is condemned to be held prisoner in the flames and the two,
uh,
tongues of fire,
literally tongues of fire because here is a rhetorician the philosopher,
the neoplatonists who actually is a rhetorician trying to persuade others about
his,
his ideas and managing and,
and,
and being a,
and being very,
um,
uh,
being very proud of this,
his success.
Uh,
but then we get caught by his own tongue.
It's homeless.
The temptation of the artist himself.
It's Daedalus who builds the labyrinth and gets caught paid.
It's the stone of the artist who becomes a captive of that which aims of,
is constructed.
This is true for Ulysses and a tradition called but his own language.
And here Dante begins with a story of the Sicilian bull,
the first victim of which who was the artist itself.
So I think it's literally a way of,
um,
of,
of reflecting on the scene that precedes it.
Virgil and Dante are interrupted lines 20,
Oh thou to my direct my voice or who just now spoke in Lombard.
What an extraordinary little,
uh,
a misreading of the language of the rhetoric deployed in the previous,
can't you remember in the previous candle damn tab has virtual go out of his way
to say,
don't know,
don't talk to these people.
Uh,
they are Greeks,
so let me talk to them.
But now from the perspective of we do the Montefeltro,
we're not speaking some kind of a Homeric,
uh,
attic,
ah,
AH,
Greek,
they're speaking a dialect of Italy,
which is to say that language language,
it's not a question of uh,
what kind of style you're using.
Language only shows this whole 12 distance.
It shows,
shows you yourself where you are,
uh,
and uh,
the kind of distance that you have from the world of truth or the kind of
proximity that you may have to some self complacency sets.
In the case of,
uh,
of,
of Ulysses.
So you who know spoke Lombard clearly,
uh,
a way of reading the pretense that rhetorical stylistic pretentions of the other
two,
uh,
speakers in the previous cancer saying,
now go that way.
I do not urge the more though have come perhaps somewhat late.
Let it not earthly to stay and speak with me and I'll see you soon.
Eric's not me and I'm burning if there has fallen.
But now into this blind world from the sweet land of Italy,
once I bring all my guilt,
Tommy,
if there are minorities,
have piece of war for most of the mountain there between Rubino and the height
where Tibor is released as opposed to the lofty rhetoric of uh,
of view loosest and the previous can't,
who speaks through the grant,
this generalities about what is the,
what is the destination and destiny and fate of human beings,
virtual knowledge,
the journaling to the west going through a hundred thousand pedals here,
the language becomes a,
this assault,
thoughtful,
deliberate diminution,
a contraction of focus as if,
uh,
the language becomes one of in lead local peace and war between neighboring
towns.
I was still bent down and so,
uh,
et cetera.
And then,
uh,
as a way of adjusting the,
the register,
the stylistic re register virtual,
we'll say to Dante speak,
thou he is Italian.
Once again on the surface,
the observance of degrees of style and,
and the laws of rhetorical decorum are always observed and now he continues or
soul,
et cetera.
Um,
and uh,
he will leave.
The pilgrim will inform,
uh,
we do the Montefeltro,
about the situation of Italy.
This is the whole paragraph on page three,
three,
seven.
And then,
uh,
we do,
goes on saying,
if I thought my aunts who are to one who'd ever returned to the world,
this flame should stay within another movement.
But since Nan ever returned alive from this depth,
if what I hear is true,
I answer the without fear of infamy.
This is a passage that most of you remember very well.
You may know this very well.
It's a passage or a Elliot,
a Tsl area to users as uh,
uh,
and the pig Ruffin epitaph actually for the love song of Prufrock.
Uh,
the,
this,
uh,
so it gives you an idea of the kind of reading that earlier it has of his own or
this the solitary this man,
uh,
Prufrock,
and,
and uh,
the kind of inferred or reality that his figure also evokes.
What I want to emphasize though here at the level of style is how we do speaks,
curses,
hypothetical sentences,
but in theoretical remarks that just a style that is deliberately goes contrary
to the smooth hi,
once again,
high style of Ulysses in the preceding preceding canter.
And then I was a main of arms and then the cold coded fryer thinking so good to
make amends.
And indeed my thoughts had come true.
But for the great priest,
here's the curse,
I guess Bonhoeffer's May ill before him who put me back in the old sense and how
and wherever.
And wherefore I would have the hear from me while I informed the bones and flesh
my mother gave me another reference to birth with,
which as you know,
characters start telling us their story,
uh,
making of birth than the first major event of their lives.
And then whatever happens,
whatever biographical account,
maybe a descent from or a deviation from the promises that that birth may have
held,
uh,
what I informed the bones,
et cetera.
Um,
my,
um,
my deeds were those noble iron bars over Fox.
This is machiavellian.
Eventually will become machiavellian language.
So we are moving into the secret halls of power.
There were big deals are struck,
the deal sell cause destruction of cities where the pole,
we'll ask the secret that advice from his counselor and let's see what he says.
I knew all wiles and covert ways and so practice their arts.
Um,
I could not,
but a remark to you how Canto 26 also takes place through the language of
concealment and covertness,
right?
Uh,
even,
uh,
which is in Italian,
it's actually the language for thievery.
At the same time,
the forgiveness of it all.
Remember Dante speaks of the sun through a paraphrased is to say there was
hidden,
uh,
the sinners are hidden and concealed from view in the tongues of fire.
This is the land where drove manipulation of the political stratagems and
machinations.
And here it becomes highlighted and make visible to us.
Uh,
so he continues the covert ways our came when I saw myself come to that part of
my life where every men should lower the sales as if it were another,
another Marriner like you and gathering the ropes that which before had pleased
me then grieve me.
And with repentance and confession,
I turned fryer and another curse war or possibly a woe is me.
It would have served the prince of the new pharisees being at war a year near
the,
at Warner,
the Lateran and not with sirens.
And so Jews for every one of his enemies was Christian and none had been asked
at the taking of Aker or treating in the land of uz Holden regarding another,
the supreme office and holy order or holy orders and himself,
nor in me that code which used to make,
it's where lean,
but it's constant.
Oh,
it's really,
we're moving within the,
I said,
I said the,
within the,
the holes of,
we say the Vatican today at the time was the Church of Saint John,
the latter on which was the residence of the for the Bishop of Rome.
Uh,
and this was famous then as it is famous now for the mosaics about Constantine's
donation to Pope Sylvester.
So the whole issue of the doughnut,
that temporal power of the papacy,
it really is to be seen as,
to be glimpse through this,
uh,
this,
a scene of a,
of widow and Bonhoeffer's.
Uh,
he asked council of me and I was silent for his words,
seemed drunken,
and then he spoke again.
This is the extraordinary catechist [inaudible] of the,
of the holy office giving,
uh,
the,
the absorb Lucian before even the commission of the crime.
You can go and do what you want.
I give you a solution before you do anything.
So it's,
it's do not let that heart,
this mistrust.
I observe,
absorb the henceforth and do that.
Teach me how many casp Palestrina to the ground.
I have power to lock and unlock the new Peter to the heaven is,
I noticed for the keys are to which my predecessor,
ah,
the,
did not hold a dear.
This is the famous story of seller Stein.
The fifth who gave up the office of the paper,
said it,
who stands even in the historical recollections and scholarship today as the
embodiment of one of a,
of a pope of a figure who understood that the drama and the issue is always
between power,
maybe a little bit too dualistically and holiness and how the two for seller
Stein,
we're really incommensurable and can not quite,
there could not be a dialectic between,
between the two.
And he gave up.
Dante refers to him,
uh,
with the little bit of a,
um,
harshness for not being heroic enough and,
and uh,
withstanding,
uh,
the tide of corruption and deciding to retreat to,
into contemplative life.
Um,
so then the way to,
let me continue,
this is a little sermon that I apologize for it and we continue with this.
Then the way the arguments drove me to the point where silence seem to me the
worst offense and I said,
and this is the advice he gives,
simple and spectacular in its simplicity.
Father,
since thou does cleanse me from this sin in which I ma I must now for I love
that I must,
I cannot.
I find the soil resistible especially because now I'm guaranteed of this
absolution.
I can really go on and do whatever I want.
So there is not just a coercion on reader,
but a kind of pleasure that he feels,
you know,
he feels now it's a necessity for him to go out and perpetrate and committee
evil.
He will,
he will perpetrate and this is the,
this is the advice,
large promises with scant observance.
We'll make the triumph in the lofty seat.
What does he say?
Make promises and plan not to keep them going and tell the people in Palestrina
they are going to respect them,
that you are going to make them even rich,
whatever you want to tell them.
Then of course,
as soon as they opened the gates of the city,
don't keep this any of these promises.
This is the every statement by the way,
that one that finds its original source in Cicero's text about rhetoric,
which is known as a,
it's not really Cicero's,
but it was thought to be Cicero's and it says,
this is the text it's taught that,
uh,
from the uh,
the person to whom it was dedicated,
it was meant for this I already nume.
Uh,
it was taught in the Middle Ages to be of sa a rhetorical treaters.
And that rhetorical cheeses is based on this whole tree.
This many other treatises are based on one premise.
That rhetoric is the art of making the city and the citizens and Gri,
uh,
in order to keep the city going.
And in a,
in a properly,
uh,
govern city promises are made and that all is going to be observed.
It's a way of explaining rhetoric in moral terms.
What Dante is saying is those kind of dictates those kinds of propositions can
easily be turned around and they are being turned around in the practice.
And the historical practice.
Then as soon as I was then Francis came for me,
there is a rivalry between Francis and the devil are fighting over the soul of
reader.
And we though is,
uh,
our Francis roses.
And we though is of course here in how I mentioned this details because you will
see,
uh,
that Dante would pick up this genre of medieval disputation when later in Prague
authorial make an a in a couple of weeks we'll,
we'll,
we'll hit the Canto Dante meets Weedo son because in this poem,
fathers and sons do not necessarily belong in the same model space and sons do
not necessarily follow the footsteps,
the footsteps of their,
of their fathers.
Um,
so you see how Dante echoes this whole scene when,
and this is a kind of brief duration.
I'm giving you a pre figuration of things to come and now we come and,
and that really want to pay a little bit of attention to this cancer 28 because
we're entering the,
the world of the truly tragic world,
uh,
that the tragic,
the most tragic section of the divine comedy.
And I mentioned that because,
uh,
from here to Ken to 33,
the story of will the arena we were going to talk about what does Dante think of
tragedy and how can he go on,
really are envisioning the tragic,
after all,
I just called the poem as he calls it a comedy.
What is the role in the place of the tragic,
is there room for the tragic vision in Dante's comedy?
And the point is that the tragic,
I want to make this point now and that will be elaborating it as we go on next
time,
especially in x time,
that tragic is never the final vision.
And I would go on even saying something now that the essence of,
of tragedy is always linguistic for that has to do with issues of the,
the inherent ambiguity's of language,
the impossibilities of decoding and decipher in what is being said by one
particular bus,
state,
one state the mentor as opposed to another.
He had Dante begins.
Then there is every fraction about tragedy.
Where are we now?
We are in Canto 28.
It's the liquidity Dantin counters.
The one figure,
uh,
the figure of Bertrand,
they'll burn who was a province,
how port,
um,
uh,
province,
our port whom done to actually admires greatly in the linguist in the,
in the treatise on language that he writes,
this famous,
I have been referring to it,
the Dave and God eloquency,
he singles him out as Dante singles out based on the bone as a great poet
because he knew how to ride the most difficult genre.
He was a province.
How port,
you know,
who they are,
the area of Provence wedged between a,
the Goulian parts of Italy and France,
the,
uh,
because he was such a great portrait because he knew how to,
rhyme and,
and right,
uh,
war poems that this is the most difficult type of poetry,
aesthetically very difficult to sustain.
And that's on the bone was a genius at this.
Now,
Dante praises him among the so called makers of this court.
This is in Canto 28th that thunderbolt.
Uh,
and let's see how Dante starts with a refraction or war.
I want to tell you a couple of things as this is sure.
A Canto,
um,
a difficult cancer.
Uh,
Dante begins with,
uh,
the story of,
by,
with a reference to,
uh,
ineffability.
Would you please read the passages?
I,
my,
my version is my English words from Kantar 28th.
The first paragraph who could,
uh,
yes,
do you want to do is,
would you like to do it?
Who could ever tell,
even with words untrammeled and the tail often repeated of all the blood and the
wounds I saw now,
surely every tongue would fail for our speech and memory have not the capacity
to take in so much.
We're all the people assembled again,
who wants in the fateful land of Apulia be weld their blood shed by the Trojans
and in the long war,
which made the high pile of spoil of rings as Levy Rights,
who does not air with those who suffered grievous strokes in the struggle with
Robert,
uh,
just card.
And those are those others whose bones are still in heath,
heaps at separate,
where every Apulia in was speechless and thereby talk to be a closer where we're
older lardo conquered without arms.
And we're one to show he's wounded limb and another his cut off.
It would be nothing to compare with the fashion of the knife ditch.
Very well read.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Excellent.
Uh,
so what does this metaphor,
it's uh,
it's the,
it's we could call it a yeah,
the option of Eh,
the,
the so called ineffability topples.
You understand what I mean by ineffability Topo say usually it's a,
a,
a device,
a poetic device where the port admits the difficulty or even in possibility of
describing a particular reality.
It's called ineffability.
It's so sublime usually has to do with uh,
let's say the vision of God.
I can not really go on whoever has seen God,
why did a mistake may have had a vision.
They always uh,
fall into the contingency,
the facticity of language that I cannot quite grasp.
Uh,
the sublime quality of what they have seen,
non deploys,
the same uh,
device for the world of that said,
let's call it for what it is,
the evil world.
It is as if hell now has its home sublimity a subprime quality that is a
parallel and counter to that which Dante will witness in the divine spectacles
at the top of paradise.
Okay.
So this is the first,
the first thing,
language cannot quite be adequate to the reality it wants to represent.
And what he's talking about now is a Oldie,
the,
he wants to describe the whole of hell and all the limbs,
the dismemberment of bodies,
uh,
from all wars that can not quite,
come close to what he has seen in,
uh,
in,
in this,
uh,
in this area of health.
This is really,
uh,
the idea.
Um,
and what Dante,
first of all,
we'll go on describing his principal than the question of the ineffability
toppers,
which we'll see what it means in the unfolding of the cantor.
Um,
and as we just continue,
and actually this,
then,
uh,
they can't really comes to a close with the meeting of,
with a port,
the transoral born.
So we go from,
uh,
the language of,
of the ineffable,
um,
and the language of the ineffable that is,
has also this little detail,
a reference to Livy,
a Roman historian and his voice and his authority are unquestioned.
Livvy cannot make mistakes.
Historians,
uh,
are entering in their chronicles,
in their accounts,
what they have seen.
But somehow the poetic voice is not quite the same thing as the historian.
Historians voice there.
See what the,
the tension is in the first few lines of the poem.
And then the,
the,
uh,
the Canto comes to a close with a,
a different form of a poetic reflection.
Uh,
Dante is here describing something all together different.
The meeting of Bhutan,
the barn.
Look how this scene,
this is the end of Canto 28.
I stayed to watch the troop and so,
and I saw a thing I should feel simply to tell without more proof and other the
threat of the ineffable.
Once again,
the port is unable to represent,
uh,
feels the difficulty of representing that,
the extraordinary quality,
what he has seen.
But that conscience reassures me the good companion,
which are Boldens Jimin under the breast plate of his felt integrity.
Verily I saw and I seem to see it's still a trunk without a head going,
as were the others of the miserable heard and it held the severed head by the
hair swinging in its hand like a lantern.
And that was looking at us and saying,
woe is me of itself.
It made for itself a lamp.
And there were two in one and one into
strange arithmetical language.
That divided body of bartender born.
He's a maker of the scored and he's being punished by having his own body
divided from itself.
I'll come back to this metaphor in a moment,
but the idea that for now stylistically is that the two is one and one is to how
it can be.
He knows who saw ordains and mathematical languages.
If there is no equality,
even possible.
Remember that it was exactly the language that he was,
he used for the metaphor,
uh,
the impossible metaphor to contain or the description of all the battlefields
and all the dead people at the beginning of Canto 28.
I cannot find the metaphor that somehow can come,
can equal,
can,
can give an idea.
I fair idea.
I proportionate idea of what I have seen in this.
Uh,
uh,
this is one on top of the other member limbs accumulated,
one on top of the other and now dentists using,
and again the language of a quantity but sort of making us think that somehow
there is some equality or some rationale and the disparity of one being too,
I don't know,
he says,
well he knows God knows who sold date.
I don't know.
That's what the statement means.
What it was just below the bridge,
a raised its harm high and with it the head.
So it's to bring its words near us.
And they were,
see now my grievous punishment,
thou who breathing goes looking on the Dead Sea,
if any other is so great,
is this clearly,
this is the first character in inhale who complaints that a punishment inflicted
on him is really beyond all justice.
Beyond all proportion.
There's no proportionality between what the punishment he gets and the crime he
has committed.
And he proceeds to explain it that main in that maze bear news of me,
know that I am birth Rhonda Byrne.
He that gave evil backing to the young king and he explains,
I made rebellion between the father and the son.
I divided father and son are kicked off hill,
did know worse,
uh,
Biblical,
typology for Absalom in David with his wicked Golding's because I parted those.
So joined I carry my brain,
alas parted from its root in this trunk,
thus is observed in me direct rebuke.
What is going on here?
Uh,
it's a number of things.
Let me just explain a few things.
Why should they fund the ball?
Uh,
the poet be the one who bears now visible the mark of the division on his own
body.
We know that this is the way punishments occur.
The idea of a punishment in hell is that a punishment is just usually the
prolongation of what the extension of what has chosen to do in this life.
You choose to,
um,
create division.
That's where you,
you,
you belong.
You did not believe in the mortality of his own.
You are always after death.
We are going to be dead,
uh,
and so on.
So,
uh,
this is the,
the,
the reflection on punishment or if you wish on the justice that regulates this
world of hair or what Dante calls the retribution that,
that the word he uses is an Italian contract.
Paso say counterpart,
I would say,
oh,
counter suffering.
Last word in Italian is Contra Paso,
which really means,
uh,
that there is pastoral comes from passion,
to suffer.
You suffer with what you have equally for what you have done.
Um,
that's it.
So it's in a sense it's really the,
uh,
not quite,
but the equivalent of the eye for the eye.
And the tooth or the tooth,
the,
the whole idea of Richard retributive justice.
There is,
there is a fair,
a fair correspondence between what you have done and what you have,
uh,
and while you are going to suffer,
um,
and,
but from the born seems to do.
Why,
what is the,
what is the issue with the body?
The whole point of this Canto,
he said that's on the board divides father and son.
He violates a principle of fundamental principle political theology whereby if
some of you are interested in this issue,
you could read the work of a historian,
a great history,
medieval historian who died actually almost half a century ago.
It's the king's two bodies by historian,
by the name of canned Toro Vicks.
Some of you may know it can't aerobics k and t or the blue eye,
et cetera.
Can't.
R O W I C C Kunturo Vicks.
And what is the idea of the king?
What you mean?
The king's two bodies?
Yes.
A king has always two bodies.
The visible party that one has and also the,
the mystical body of the royalty.
They used to say in the Middle Ages,
and we still do.
Maybe if you are in new to the news about royalty,
the king is dead long live the king.
The king never dies and the king never dies because he always two bodies.
There are two bodies of the king.
I may die as an incumbent by the office of the king always remains.
Okay.
This is fundamental.
That's one idea.
So by dividing the father from the sun,
uh,
Nantais has Beltran,
the bone,
a bleaching,
the unity of the mystical body of the king.
That two father and son are really one.
The other metaphor that is behind that,
which are,
we already saw a little bit,
uh,
um,
sort of,
uh,
traced a finally traced,
in the,
in the cantor of uh,
uh,
Chuck Coyne Canto six of of in was the idea of the body politic that I paid that
you,
you may remember,
you remember I mentioned to you,
uh,
the famous fable of millennials who thinks that the body,
the city is really constructed like a body in organic,
uh,
a set of correspondences,
organic correspondences like the human body.
Uh,
there is no difference between,
there is a difference between patricians and Plebeians.
That's menus argument,
but they're all part of one orga organic,
unified whole that is true for the body politic from a Roman point of view,
but it's also the principal was so called mystical body of the church.
The same Paul in the letter to the Ephesians refers to the church is the
mystical body of Christ.
They kind of so that the state becomes a secular canter,
a secular,
a extension of this mystical body.
The church,
we are all members.
Some of us are thumbs,
others are just toes or whatever,
whatever.
In this body,
the mystical body of Christ,
I mentioned this because Kantar 28,
you have a political focus on the the Rome or but they're born,
uh,
breaching the unity of father and son.
But also reference to Muhammad.
And I know that there are a lot of people who just find this just absolutely the
audience that Mohammad should be placed or the,
the,
the profit should be praised here in this area of,
in fairness,
the only argument that one can have about this is for Dante.
Mohammed was actually a member of the church who created a schism,
which is different from Harrison.
You know,
we saw the heretics and can't are nine and 10.
The heretics are those who do not believe in certain,
uh,
tenets of the doctrine.
The schisms are those who want to double,
who divide there would schism in Greek means to tear apart the unity,
the world of unity and dabbling it.
Okay.
So this is really,
um,
the,
the argument,
uh,
some of the,
the,
the symbols and images of Canto 28,
but let me go to the actual heart of is probably the question of justice.
Uh,
and the question of Bertrando born who will go back to that,
uh,
when I was just build a bridge,
see now my grievance punishment that who breathing goes,
looking on the Dead Sea,
if any other is so greatest,
this,
that time things that there is no justice in this hellish world that he inhabits
a,
all the ideas that uh,
uh,
the ethics of our store to really account for the vices that are so prevalent
here is just not true.
Not only that's not true,
uh,
this idea of the retribution,
is it,
is it an idea,
this idea of the Contra Paso there,
uh,
is that an idea that really believes in that is a lot of,
what kind of justice is that,
where the justice that we have in,
in Fandom,
and let me just give you a little bit of a piece of intellectual history about
this whole issue.
And I want to make it very simple,
but it's really not a difficult problem anyway.
It's not that I'm,
I'm,
I'm simplifying the issues.
They are two types.
The people who think that the thinkers who think about this issue,
of course our store too in the ethics and Dante's aware of the great commentary
on Aristotle's ethics by Thomas Aquinas.
He keeps them in mind and,
and uh,
they discuss justice and they wonder what is justice to this is a great problem
for that.
It was Dante is,
I have been calling him a number of things,
but he's clearly a poet of justice.
He really believes that whole point of his quest is to establish some degree of
justice in his soul,
try to find out justice in the city and,
and,
and probe the possibility of some universal justice as opposed to look Christian
ideas of anarchy and chaos in the cosmos.
So there can be some continuity between the outside and the inside world.
So what is the idea of justice is what meant types of justice?
Do they have?
They usually think about two types of justice.
This whole called the retributive justice,
which is the one that we have in hair here,
but also this reparative justice.
That's Dante is Dante where of the two forms?
Yes.
It's impossible not to think of the representation of the wheel of fortune in in
in fairness seven as anything less than a case of distributive justice and
distributive justice follows.
An arithmetical model.
There is to say in a distributive justice is imagine that wheel of fortune.
Some have more,
some have less,
some have less.
If someone has five you want to establish some justice you take away from one
was five and gift one was zero or or one and you create some kind of equality.
Distributive Justice has equality as it's a in retributive justice.
Things that are a little bit different because if I say and Aquinas reflects on
this,
this is not a concern of at all of our historical,
if I say an eye for an eye and a tooth for tooth,
am I really establishing justice or am I just dabbling the the offense as had
been perpetrated.
If someone takes an eye plucks and I are of me,
uh,
if I do the same,
whoever has damaged me that way.
Am I having,
am I being restored in my original position?
No,
no.
That doesn't happen too.
How do you,
how does one go around thinking about the whole question of retributive Justice
Aquinas,
and this is also Aristo who goes on things as well.
Of course it's hard.
It's very difficult to find the exact counterparts between crime and punishment.
If,
if,
if a clown were to um,
slap the king,
it's not enough for the king to slap the crown clown bag because one might say,
well it's the,
say it's one slab.
There is the violation of the office and then both,
uh,
Aristotle that is implied and that can never quite be restored by having the
king slap the clown bed.
Both that is total and Aquinas.
That's why money was invented.
So one can really give whatever there is a principle of inequality can go on
repaying it through other forms,
other punishments.
The fact is I think that Dante,
first of all,
I want to go back to the structure of the camp.
It's crucial that Dante should think about this fundamental problem of justice,
which is the aim of the ethical structure of the poem.
And in fairness in particular through a poet through Bertrand,
the bar,
not only three report,
it's Dante himself has just been announcing the possibility of finding through
language,
the exact metaphor,
the exact correspondence between the reality and this sort of presentation.
What Dante is doing is telling us how arbitrary are his own judgments in hell,
how the notion of a precision in uh,
in the way punishments and,
uh,
crimes are related are never quite reliable.
And this is the to understand this and they know that I,
I did not ask you to read it for today,
but I have to,
I have a few minutes and I want to go to the ask you to turn to the very
beginning of Canto 29th,
because I think it becomes a retrospective gloss here on the problems that had
been trying to explain and Canto 28 Dante goes through and other forms of,
he will enter the world of this whole called the alchemists.
Uh,
uh,
those were engaged in diabolical mutations and natural mutations,
personifications impersonators,
uh,
disguises,
etc. But before he gets there,
there is a little long passage.
It's the first time in the whole poem that usually,
you know how what the Co,
the narrative economy of each canto is.
Dante comes to the end of the point of,
of a canto and usually closest off with a particular scene or particular sinner.
This is an exception.
Dante goes into cancer 29 and Dick,
wherever situation he has been describing cancer 28 keeps reappearing,
worries him in some,
I want to see what worries him about this.
The many people in the strange wounds had made my eyes so drunk that they were
failing to stay in we.
But Virgil said to me,
what are those still gazing at?
Pilgrim is looking back at what he has seen.
Why does that's the,
it looks the rest down there among the miserable main shades that has not done
this at the other depth.
Consider if they'll thing to number them that the valley goes 22 miles round and
already the moon is beneath our feet.
That time is no short.
That is allowed to us.
And there is more to see the no,
he's uh,
here once again,
uh,
numbers or in medical language,
what is the,
what is the measure?
What is the,
how do we measure how,
how are we going to determine where is the exact correspondence?
I just,
just do,
let me give you a little,
uh,
aside about this.
Um,
uh,
you know,
a great reader of him fan and actually he began his career as a commentator of
Dante was Galileo the scientist.
That was the first work that he did.
He published a famous,
uh,
work on,
on,
on in fairness,
he tried to find out what the actual,
um,
size over the Holo in federal was just by going by this little detail of it
without that gives the radius and he comes up with the idea that in fairness as
large as they sit to Florence,
uh,
which is something I probably would have said anyway.
When I was at mathematical,
there was a mathematical proof for it or just his old joke.
Uh,
I'll leave it to you to decide.
Let me continue with this.
If thou had Steven heed to my reason for looking,
I answered then perhaps that would just have granted me a longer stay.
Meantime,
the leader was going on and I went after him already making my reply and they
added within that then what are held my eyes.
So in 10,
three,
just now,
I think a spirit it kinsmen of is one of my blood.
We for the guilt that cost so much.
Now
Dante knows that a relative of his is in this den of hell.
Then said the mass,
let not thy thoughts with distracted about him henceforth at 10 12 things and
let him stay there for,
I saw him below the bridge,
pointed the and threatened fiercely with his finger and I heard them called
Jerry del Bello reminding him,
yeah,
I'm here I am.
That was so holy occupied with him who once held hot forth.
The doubt is not look that way until he was gone and Nantais response or my
leader,
I said the violent death which yes is yet and avenged for him by any,
there is a partner.
The shame made him indignant and for that reason is I drudge.
He went on without speaking to me and by this has made me more compassionate
with him.
What's going on?
How is this related to the previous cancer and I think,
I think it's fairly clear Dante meets a kinsman of is who has been killed and
that death is an avenged and clearly is going to be an avenged is going to
remain an event.
Dante's so overwhelm by pity and compassion.
But he does not say no.
Does he promised that he's going to go out and take revenge against the carers
of his,
his relative Jerry there Bedloe what he's doing is redefining the notion of
justice.
The idea that justice is doubling or could be of the crime.
You know,
someone is doing something.
Here's a kinsman of mine,
I'm going to go out and kill your kinsmen cause that's the way justice could be
understood.
The idea of justice as revenge,
as a way of establishing the precise relationship is what is giving up here
completely.
It's retrospectively and gloss on what I have been saying,
that the notion of justice as the iPhone,
AI or the tooth for the tools is no longer valid in this context,
no longer valid.
And I think this is the beginning then of Dante's worrying about,
uh,
what is the nature of God's justice,
what is,
how arbitrary is my own claim of authority in describing this very issues and
uh,
and continuing with this reflection as we shall see a next time.
So we,
uh,
let me see if there are questions now.
And,
uh,
I bought this whole problem of the problems we've been dealing with today or bit
of a problem.
Yes,
I am curious.
The question is how knowledgeable [inaudible] was of the Hellenic world since he
did not read Greek.
And my answer is yes,
indeed.
He did not read Greek,
uh,
at all.
Um,
he,
uh,
for that matter,
no.
Did piners really read Greek?
Uh,
but so he knew the Hellenic world through Latin translation of texts,
like car adis daughters,
uh,
was being the ethics,
the tree,
the soul Plato.
He knew,
he knew medieval romances that we'll be dealing with a so called,
you know,
medieval romances,
deal with the matters of France,
the matters of Rome,
the mattress of Brittany.
Uh,
the role mom of Alexander,
which is part of a,
the Hellenic world.
He knew the,
uh,
he lived,
which,
um,
it was parked by the way,
till the year 1200 and more,
and later was part of the eggs are k,
um,
a Greek hex or k the church over Aveda was a ex arcade as it's cold.
Um,
so he,
he knew,
he knew this,
this is the,
where the resources and the conduit of,
uh,
his knowledge of the Greek world,
Latin and whatever survives in Latin.
I mean,
I'm fully philosophical schools of the Greeks,
clearly Cicero on the ends of man,
the Feebles,
uh,
that is really the,
the source book for whatever He,
I had been saying about [inaudible] aliens,
uh,
et Cetera.
Um,
he had some idea,
Dante,
some idea of the metaphysics.
I mean,
he rides about,
uh,
um,
the [inaudible] that's about the need to go next.
Ethics and metaphysics for instance.
So he knew that that's what he knew.
Um,
I could even add that,
I'm sure that actually that is going to be in Washington DC in about a year.
Are we going to have a conference?
We're going to hold it in court and,
and,
and uh,
in Washington for a number of reasons about the,
on Dantin the Greeks.
So if you're staying in touch with me,
I'll let you know what happens.
But one thing that we are really looking at her,
the mosaics,
the art world that come,
the,
the relations,
the connections with,
um,
with a Greek artists.
We'll be traveling and,
uh,
we're in Rome,
in Sicily.
Yes.
That's what he knew.
What is it appropriate to move on from contra positive punishment for God to
keep it in place?
In how,
how does he reconcile those two things that hell is supposedly adjust plays?
He's not supposed to look back towards like cans of 28 and he's not supposed to.
Yeah.
Well,
the question is,
uh,
going back to the promoter of justice,
in Canto 28 and then 29,
how can they go on,
um,
having some kind of hesitations about the idea of justice and at the same time
hold that place in a hell in,
up,
in place according to some criteria.
Uh,
and,
and the ends,
uh,
is,
um,
it may be a little bit,
we'll appeared a little bit complicated,
but I'm not sure that it's complicated.
Uh,
this whole language drove doubts about authority,
that Dante has the authority of himself as the one who can administer justice.
The Authority about,
uh,
the,
the himself as a even capable of,
uh,
remembering that we hit,
which,
which he has seen.
And therefore the,
um,
the authority of the poetic voice,
this is very extensive and really goes into,
into all directions,
has a counter with,
that's not the only aspect,
the only facet of Dante's a text.
The way I see that there's,
that he's also capable of taking on a prophetic voice,
um,
so that he,
he appears as the one who has by singular grace of God,
been chosen tool,
uh,
explore the,
the,
the world in the beyond,
which is really cold and then the student the most physical and direct way.
So the two voices are simultaneously present.
And so how does one,
uh,
condition the other?
I think that that is a really,
the tension of this poem.
Um,
the,
uh,
Dante Dante is as both a profit.
And Dante is the poet who knows the arbitrators of this construction.
He's the poet,
theologian.
And the port,
uh,
the,
the point that calligraphy Sta,
uh,
the two voices.
So I said,
well,
tennis,
we present.
And what is the point of doing this is in many ways this makes the poem the
actual experience of a pilgrimage.
That is to say it's how you connect yourself.
A kind of judgment to you give of what of the realities that Dante's represented
there is going to reveal to you yourself,
who you are and where you are.
It's a way of shifting the point of Dante's,
the fault,
the port,
the voice of the master who can tell you how things are to the interpretive
journey,
to an allegorical journey.
You're going to this Haifa and all the time involve yourself in,
uh,
in the story.
This can be,
can turn out.
I think this is his wish.
The story,
which is his journey can turn out to be your journey.
You can tell your own story.
Do you see what I'm saying?
And that's,
I think the,
it's a very good question and I hope I've been clear in answering this.
You may agree or not agree with it.
That's,
that's another story.
But I hope we've been really clear in the answer.
Yes.
In terms of the narrow issue of justice,
do you think that Dante doesn't have so much a problem with the system of eye
for an eye as with the idea that only someone with the intelligence of God could
like accurately see the correspondences and prescribe the right punishments for
the time?
So it's not that like the actual system is bad,
it's just that Dante is humans can't presume to make those judgements.
Yes,
ma'am.
Uh,
the,
the other question that follows the followup question is that,
does it mean that Dante may can one say that Dante actually,
it doesn't have problems with a basic structure,
but only with the human ability to grasp how it works.
And I would agree with that.
I would agree with that.
Yeah.
The,
however,
I think that what he's really has has problems with is the notion,
which was a practice at the time,
the notion of revenge,
the way of understanding justice says revenge.
Now even the Bible will go on and tell you that the,
the,
that revenge is mine.
So says the Lord,
but then two would say that's God's voice and not the human voice.
So he clearly has an objection to that.
And is there some implication because that's really,
I think what you were asking me.
I hope that's what you're asking me.
Otherwise I'm completely off.
Is there some implication that the university itself,
it's divine economy,
they may be something come fathomable and I would say yes,
that they called question of justice.
It is something that we can not quite measure with human instruments.
So there's one great metaphor.
The Dante we'll give in Canto I believe 19 of paradise where he goes back again
to the question of justice and he talks about justice in terms of the salvation
of uh,
uh,
the handles,
you know,
why shouldn't they be here and what he had.
He wonders about that and the answer that he gives us,
he says,
the question of justice is like this.
See when you are really near the shore,
you see the bottom and everything seems to be that water's a clear and
transparent and you really seem to touch bottom and see the bottom.
As soon as you go in,
then the unfathomable ocean takes over.
And the foundation of the ground of it all remains invisible and inaccessible.
Do you see what,
uh,
what the argument,
that's the argument that goes on giving.
It's not an issue that he has resolved here once and for all.
He will go back to these questions.
I have a question about the term you're using earlier.
What are we,
when you were talking about they ineffability um,
I couldn't make out if you were saying the it of ineffability trope.
Yeah.
I called it cause it's really jog.
The question is I'm using a ineffability trope.
Uh,
it's a,
it's more than a trope.
We say it's a device.
I call the top Os,
which is a place where some,
um,
you know,
they talk about top.
Was it something that keeps like a type we're keeping,
keeps repeating and can be used.
Dante uses this,
uh,
idea of ineffability what he's really talking about,
the impossible,
metaphoric,
and hold the represent two different realities.
And I think that that's exactly the way he wants us to think of a crime and
punishment.
Okay.
And then a relationship between crime and punishment,
which is a metaphorical one,
which is a kind of relationship at the tries to equal relationship between two
terms.
I call it topples,
a Greek word.
We call it common place.
It's place.
God says a commonplace.
Okay.
We'll see you next time.